cops promise blood on your heads
I will find you many cops hate we're
still 18 years why were they here they
responded to a robbery people gonna rob
660 pounds of coke
you drive a BMW door to the job did you
bring just one other guy with you did
you only take 50 keys it's easy to dumb
luck all set up
to shoot us
automatic weapons settings Attila to
killer
and refused
to allow these families to be
traumatized with trials and appeals and
parole hearings I'm asking you to
protect them from that I understand
everything about these guys has been
confident so far
close the island Rhode Island then had
21 bridges and shut him down three
rivers closing four times block
yeah cannot be some version of this
where these two are found
none of this makes sense because what is
rewarded us this whole thing is filthy
[Music]
what's going on here someone's trying to
see you out
these cops live at the city that
actively dislikes them
listen they still protect with their
lives I just need the truck you go down
this road you're on your own
you do wrong dear train but he does not
bear the sword in pain the very top arm
belongs cops or criminals if you have
blood on your head
I will find you
[Music]
you